on a business park in cardiff the new
space frontier is taking shape it's a
satellite but unlike any other
space forge is building the first
orbiting factory that will use
microgravity to make metal alloys and
semiconductors that are impossible to
create on earth
it's the plummeting cost to launch a
rocket now as little as 830 pounds a
kilogram that makes it viable probably
within the next
maybe five certainly ten years
something you interact with on a daily
basis will have a component made in
space whether it's the national grid
that you get your power off to your
house from or maybe it's in the the
train that you're traveling on it's
definitely going to be in sort of the
larger parts of infrastructure that
where energy efficiency is really key to
reducing our carbon footprints
space forge will be among several
british companies with satellites on the
first ever rocket to launch from the uk
this september
but put aside all thought of a
traditional rocket blasting off from a
launch pad britain's first liftoff will
use the same runway as the holiday
flights at newquay airport and the
journey to space starts on a jumbo jet
virgin orbit uses cosmic girl to carry a
20 meter rocket above the clouds it's
done it from california but from newquay
the plane will head over the atlantic
then fire the engine when on the perfect
trajectory to put satellites into an
orbit that passes over the north and
south poles she can now become a
critical part of launch infrastructure
and really give that rocket its first
step 35 000 feet the better part of mach
one two thirds of the way through the
atmosphere before the rocket has to do
any work at all
the super clean facility for putting
satellites inside the rocket is being
fitted out but there's no other
infrastructure needed which keeps costs
down the spaceport will bring good
year-round jobs to one of the uk's most
deprived regions we're looking at 150
direct jobs just from spaceport alone
and that's already happening
but we're looking at another about 240
in the supply chain ancillary facilities
and activity that will be happening to
support launch over the years
the new facilities we're building will
house lots of different companies that
are already signing up to to locate here
and do lots of different activities in
the space industry
the uk is already a satellite building
superpower having its own spaceport the
first in europe will put rocket boosters
under an already booming space industry
thomas more sky news in newquay